sorry first week on new flatbeds Oh  where's my poster gone oh I thought this  was better for the kitchen we should you  like to know ID like I know they're like  I love having something I love to look  at when I'm getting the vacuum cleaner  but in the cupboard Jerry you need to  close the packet off you've eaten the  crackers otherwise they go stale they're  all stale now yeah that's the point  what okay  I like stale cracker country food which  as you'll see it's the same as cereal  that's why I always do the boxes ooh  laughs  hmm why me  where's Earl is he  oops this is who I am I'm a creative I  can't help it  do you think you could try to help it  that's a bit unreasonable well don't do  that now I feel bad  what are you doing I always tried to Lao  music sorry tears that's who I am  forty-three  you  you